[Musique]
quel monde après la crise planétaire du
comic 19
[Musique]
notre modèle de consommation doit-il
être remise en question
a model basé sur la mondialisation des
denrées critiqué aujourd'hui
et si la solution était l'autosuffisance
alimentaire
à l'image des néoruraux ces citadins
venus s'installer à la campagne dans les
années 70 quand on est un parisien on se
rend pas compte de tous les efforts
qu'il a fallu pour produire les aliments
qu'on trouve au marché c'est vraiment
quand on vient dans la nature et qu'on
veut les produire soi-même qu'on se rend
compte de tous les problèmes que ça
représente
à l'époque mai 68 a bouleversé les
moeurs les modes de vie changent et la
société évolue le cultiver chez soi pour
soi c'était l'objectif de ces jeunes
dans le sud de la france en 1960 domus
de jardin donne des légumes 3 hectares
de terres ont été défrichés irrité
labourer et préparer à la semaine il y à
des lapins des poules des moutons dirige
personne ne meurt de faim
l'autosuffisance alimentaire
une expérience pour certains un mode de
vie qui dure pour d'autres parmi ses
adeptes vie cultivé et consommer pour
soi il est annick gillen en 2011
ce couple installé en loire-atlantique
vivait en totale autonomie alimentaire
et ce depuis 1975
grâce à leur potager de 200 mètres
carrés il arrivait à se nourrir toute
l'année nous on a dépassé la soixantaine
la vie c'est bien autre chose
c'est-à-dire le respect de
l'environnement et des générations à
venir et l'équilibré à travers la nature
l'autosuffisance alimentaire des
personnalités aussi l'ont adopté et
tente d'en être des porte parole à
l'image de l'essayiste et agriculteurs
pierre rabhi en 2014 entente l'autonomie
pas l'autarcie mais l'autonomie salaires
pouvoir produire le maximum de ce que
nous pouvons produire pour soi oui mais
comment faire sans potager la solution d
incroyables comestibles l'on trouvait
depuis 2012 ce mouvement écologiste
installe des potagers au coeur des
villes à destination de tous les
habitants
gratuitement aujourd'hui la proposition
d incroyables comestibles c'est
d'atteindre l'autosuffisance alimentaire
par le choix conscient de manger local
de manger bio de manger solidaire avec
les circuits courts c'est tout à fait
possible
ces dernières années les initiatives se
multiplient en 2016 la ville de rennes
s'est lancé dans un pari ambitieux celui
d'atteindre l'autosuffisance alimentaire
pour ses 210 mille habitants grâce au
potager et verger urbain chaque rennais
est invité à planter semer et récolter
des fruits et légumes
[Musique]